et je vois la sublime Adèle
Exarchopoulos
bonsoir Adèle vous êtes merveilleuse
comme d'habitude non mais ce soir pour
le film Rien à vous êtes la seule
nomination pour ce film mais quel
nomination nommé donc dans la catégorie
meilleur actrice un rôle fort une
errance c'est compliqué vous êtes
pratiquement de tous les plans vous
portez littéralement ce film donc cette
nomination je pense qu'elle doit avoir
une saveur particulière aussi pour vous
bah sincèrement il y a déjà cette
catégorie ou pas c'était une espérée
mais pour moi c'est quand même
incroyable et puis après ce film c'est
il me tient à cœur parce que c'est
vraiment la preuve vu les conditions
dans lesquelles on la tournée c'est
vraiment la preuve que quand tu fais les
choses avec le coeur quelque soit les
conditions les conditions si les
convictions sont là bah en fait ça vaut
la peine et c'est vrai qu'il a fait un
chemin petit budget c'est un petit film
c'est le tiers du film c'est filmé à
l'iPhone on se maquille et nous-mêmes on
était toujours quatre on a tourné sans
autorisation parfois dans dans certains
pays donc je suis vraiment fier d'être
et c'est pour ce film parce que je suis
très fier de ce film vous pouvez l'être
vous avez un mantra dans le votre
personnage sur tinder son pseudo sur les
gens
son mantra sur tinder c'est Carpe Diem
est-ce que c'est un mantra qui vous
parle dans la vie c'est à dire que déjà
Carpe Diem Carpe Diem ça veut dire
comme ça
allait très bien si je devais en choisir
un serait peut-être pas celui-là moi je
trouve que ce qui compte c'est vraiment
de vivre les choses ça va être qui tu
les vis en fait quel que soit les choses
soient des épreuves ou des moments de
joie en tout cas ce qui compte pour moi
c'est avec qui avec qui je traverse ça
alors avec qui vous allez traverser le
CV alors
déjà quoi qu'il arrive ça qui est beau
c'est que je retrouve à mes amis afin de
cette soirée ma mère elle a pris un jour
off
pour ça je trouve ça trop mignon pour
regarder la cérémonie et je viens avec
une amie avec laquelle je travaille Nour
mais que mon ami aujourd'hui je rappelle
que vous avez déjà eu le César du
meilleur espoir vous l'avez mis où ce
César
je l'ai mis vous l'avez gardé oui je
l'ai gardé il est chez mes parents c'est
sûr et les mémoire bon et celui de ce
soir alors il sera où ce soir je sais
pas déjà je suis là ce soir je suis trop
contente écoutez merci beaucoup merci
pense à vous on croise les doigts c'est
gentil merci bonne soirée merci